because we're now up to 19 teams maybe
19 with an asterisk because there was a
report that texans players were going to
not be at the
voluntary offseason workouts but there
hasn't been that same statement we've
seen from 19 other teams all issued
through the nflpa
as to whether to what extent their guys
are going to be there and some of them
chris like the eagles they make it clear
none of our guys are going to be there
others say many won't be there roster
but not roster bonus i always say roster
instead of workout workout bonus a
factor because you've got to be there
you've got to physically be there in
phase one
and two and three all three phases at
least 90 percent of the time it
typically is to get your payment
the virtual participation available
for your per diem which is 275 dollars
you can go to the meetings virtually but
you got to be in the building to work
out to get your workout bonus at least
the 90
of the total workouts so look this
continues to be an issue between the
league and the union i continue to
believe it's not about the pandemic i
think it's about guys being upset about
the last cba guys being upset about 17
games veteran players not wanting to
show up at all someone explained to me
over the weekend
you got plenty of guys now who have
their own personal workout room that
they think are superior
to what the strength and conditioning
coaches meet out when they show up for
the off-season workouts and they'd
rather do it themselves odell beckham jr
has been doing that his whole career
he's got his own thing that he does so
you know whatever it is however it is a
lot of these guys just don't want to be
there and they're not going to be there
especially if they don't feel a
compulsion because of a workout bonus or
their roster spots in some sort of
jeopardy no i mean yes i mean to all of
that
again i mean is this a necessity that
they have to be there
no it's not it's definitely not and you
know are there of course yeah the the
day and age we're in right now 2020 with
or 2021 with all the personal trainers
and of course sports science being where
it's at i mean it's not the necessity to
have to be at the facility to grind it
out every day like it used to be but i
think i still think that's like again we
talked about it's not the workouts i'm
necessarily all that worried about
it's the on the field football stuff
and that's the big thing and listen the
other thing too
with all of this
hey it's great like yeah i the odell
beckham juniors of the world the tom
brady's of the world those guys they're
gonna work i'm not you're not worried
about them
you're not
but there are other guys of course that
you do have to worry about on an nfl
roster i mean again this is you know to
me it's not the best avenue for the
players as a whole i don't and i think
you're right i think the cba the 17 game
year the fact that the season went on
last year and hey yeah it was a success
of course it was we watched it was fun
there was a super bowl all that i think
players are looking at it like you know
okay we made it we got it done no big
deal and that's kind of their mindset
here and uh yeah you might get away with
it for a certain time but i don't know
if that's gonna help you know all the
players out in the nflpa that's for sure
and to the extent that the union is
trying to send a message to the owners
the reality is and i've heard this from
multiple folks over the past few days
the owners
don't
care you know why they don't care chris
it's costing them no money yeah they
will still have a team come september
there will be 53 players 46 in uniform
they will go play their games it's up to
the coach to make sure that the best
compliment of players is on the field
it's a thing that that rankles the
coaches because it makes it harder for
them to teach if the players aren't
there but there's a there's a compromise
lurking and the packers have struck a
tone that if other teams would do this
it possibly could solve it one team at a
time i think the ravens also have
offered this to the players basically
it's this for phase one
as long as you
participate in the virtual meetings and
have your own workout plan you get
credit toward your workout bonus you
don't have to work out in the facility
during the four weeks of phase one yeah
okay that four weeks you you're good to
go wherever you are we need you here for
phase two we need you here for phase
three to get your workout bonus but for
your workout bonus credit and the
packers have five million dollars in
player workout bonuses so this is a big
issue for them they've made it clear to
their players you can stay where you are
for the first four weeks participate in
the meetings get in your workout it's
all voluntary if you get injured you're
you're on your own but but we will treat
you working out on your own as credit
towards your workout bonus i think that
will go a long way toward
getting guys especially guys with
workout bonuses to find a way to thread
that needle where they'll show up for
phase two and phase three for the on
field stuff and they'll stay home for
the first four and do what they need to
do to get themselves in shape more teams
should consider that that could help
kind of break this log jam i think that
would be great i think that would
benefit all i mean i really do i think
that benefits organizations it benefits
the coaches i think ultimately it
benefits the players too yeah okay you
get a few a little extra time to go
about it you know in the process your
own speed and pace yeah you got to be
there for the meetings but the workouts
are going to be on you you know but then
yeah you're going to come there and
you're going to have to
be on the field a little bit and of
course we're going to evaluate what
you've been like you know working out
are you in shape are you ready to go and
do those type of things you know green
bay has always been a team that's had a
part of these things a part of their
their contracts because they want
players to be there in the offseason
green bay is one of those teams where
like yeah a lot of the players they're
there during the season and they live
somewhere else in the off season so this
gets everybody back in the building
doing that type of stuff but yeah i
would think this is a compromise that
could be made mike i mean
again
i mean i guess i'm just still a little
shocked that the players
you know want to be away so aggressively
so long
and not be on the field a little bit
more for the otas and things like that
well
and and you've said this in the past as
it relates to
the quality of
the
rehab services that a team has available
to players the difference in
the training and i don't want to speak
ill of any nfl training staff but you
pointed out a lot of these guys
get
better stuff on their own right
stuff that's fully permissible within
the realms of the ped policy but they
have better techniques better strategies
better ways to address their physical
problems on their own so it would stand
to reason that some of them are going to
believe they've got better ways to get
in shape stay in shape be in the shape
they want to be in
doing their own thing not whatever it is
the strength and conditioning coach has
thrown together for everyone i don't
know how personalized those workout
plans are but obviously when a guy goes
and gets one on his own it is intensely
individualized to his needs his desires
his objectives yeah no it is and and
listen it's a positive thing
you know it is for from that standpoint
as as like a nfl football player when
you do train with your team yeah of
course it's 90 guys there the the
strength and conditioning coach he can't
give 90 different workouts so you're
kind of lumped together with guys that
have similar size body mass all those
type of things yeah o linemen and d lime
and do a lot of the same exercises you
know quarterbacks will kind of be placed
together at times with wide receivers
and running backs and all of that type
of stuff so yeah we're not exactly all
the same type of athletes you know so
yes that's why a lot of football players
they like their own trainer
and you know their own physical rehab
stuff because it's more to them and yes
the point still you know nfl you know
rehab and all that is still behind you
know the eight ball as far as technology
and all that to me again
i'm not necessarily so worried about the
workouts themselves even though again i
do worry about that i'm not worried
about the nfl superstars and the guys
that are great players working out but
like with the reason there are
conditioning tests are because players
have shown through the years that if you
give them too much time off they don't
come back in condition right because no
one was there to put the hot poker on
their butt to go like let's go we got to
work we got to do that you know so
there's that faction in the league you
worry about but ultimately it is the on
the field work that's the most important
and i think it's the most important for
the player the team the coaches all of
that but most importantly the player and
those movements and techniques and doing
that you know and especially the young
guys like we've talked about mike and
that to me is where
you know if i'm a player there's no way
you're keeping me off the field for otas
and some of that stuff
and that's where it's going to be i
think challenging to define victory and
defeat as it relates to this effort by
the union the union quite possibly will
declare victory if players stay away
from phase one and then when phase two
and phase three roll around after the
rookie mini camp which is going to
coincide with phase two where you got 50
guys in the building
draft picks undrafted free agents try
out players eligible
second and third year players for
example a jordan love in green bay will
be eligible to participate in the rookie
mini camp and get some reps that way
he's a guy who didn't get many reps at
all last year
once you see guys showing up for
on-field work i could see the players
showing up
and
and saying we won because for four weeks
of the off-season workout program we
held together we stayed away we
boycotted this we worked out on our own
and we're here for the things we need to
be here for to help ourselves continue
our preparation for the season to learn
the playbook etc that could be a way
that the union tries to thread the
needle to say we stood up to the man and
we won
and now the game's over because for
these otas we were always going to be
here for those
now that's a little disingenuous yeah
because they supposedly have concerns
about being in the facility so his
concerns presumably would still
exist for phase two and three but i they
they really aren't
this whole pandemic thing is a pretext
that this is a power play by the union
the pandemic is a convenient excuse to
get the public on their side it seems
pandemic is a it's a lie the idea that
they don't want to be there because of
the pandemic is a flat out lie they
don't care about the pandemic and if you
do go get vaccinated
that's that's that's how you show that
you care about the pandemic yeah i mean
i'm i'm with you mike i don't think
that's really the reason either i mean
the nfl i think made it pretty clear
last week you made it pretty clear
towards the end of last week about the
protocols and testing that was still
going to be in place you know for the
player so uh yeah while the environment
out there is not perfect yet
it's still plenty safe and you know also
yeah i'm i'm with you in the fact that i
think you know again the majority of
these players are going to be go
training and doing things and putting
themselves in way more dangerous you
know situations than they would be if
they were going to a facility and being
tested on a daily basis anyways you know
i don't think it's like oh yeah i don't
want to go to the facility i'm going to
work out of my own and make sure i you
know quarantine and stay don't go near
anybody during my workouts here during
this whole time period there's no way
that's going to happen guys are going to
work out together and not be wearing
masks and being around each other and
not even really be caring about the
pandemic when it comes to working out so
yeah i think that's a total bs excuse
from the nflpa right now
one last point then we'll take a break i
can't help but wonder whether some
coaches
will
take a be careful what you wish for
approach to some of the veteran players
that they believe don't want to be there
and maybe spend a little extra time
scrutinizing the younger guys a little
more time developing a younger guy a
little more time making that leap of
faith yeah that we can keep the guy
who's making 700 000 and dump the guy
who's due to make seven million i think
that's the risk here that you pissed the
coach off sure and even though it's all
voluntary it's all voluntary they can't
do or say anything to suggest it's not
well when it comes time to pick who's on
the final roster that's when they get
their revenge even if it's served a
little bit cold i i don't disagree with
you there i don't you know yeah the
economics that says something about it
certainly and will that motivate coaches
to
close maybe the talent gap or the
knowledge gap for that guy like you're
talking about who is making 800 000 a
year you know to motivate him to get
that guy to compete with the guy who's
making you know five or six million
dollars a year and maybe take his spot
yeah i think there's gonna be some of
that it is gonna piss coaches off you
know coaches you've been around them
enough they're old school that's the way
they think oh you don't want to be here
all right well he must not love football
that way they're going to have that
thought that's the way they think you
know they're not the same you know
they're a little psycho that way so i do
i think it will hurt some of these
veteran players uh that stay away in
certain situations
i just had a vision of your guy johnny
gruden walking into the locker room and
no one there
and all the profanities that will emerge
from his pie hole right when he sees
that they all decided because they're
one of the 19 teams they're all gone
there your team's not here john you're
already upset you don't have access to
them from january to april april's here
you can have access to them and they
ain't here the only way you have access
to them is through your laptop guys
don't want to work anymore
[Laughter]
i mean jeez what year are we in that
something like that is what he'd say
yeah absolutely and you know the thing
on workout bonuses and then we'll take
our break i've been promising it for
three minutes but i could see more teams
using the workout bonuses on a
widespread basis going forward to nip
this problem in the bud
because the four teams that have heavy
workout bonuses jaguars chiefs bills
packers they're not even getting
squeezed by the union to have you guys
stay away so it's time to negotiate
these contracts and that's the way the
agents can solve this problem too well
you know the team said this is what it's
got to be it's got to be 500 000 workout
bonus that's they don't want to put it
in salary they don't want to put it in a
roster bonus it's got to be a workout
bonus what can i tell you yeah and then
that's that and it's resolved then and
that way then everybody's hands are tied
they're going to have to show up to get
their
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports